let's keep working together and wire up
the view now previously when we were
doing Model View octopus the octopus was
grabbing onto these elements by their
IDs and then updating them whenever view
dot render guide called now knockout
doesn't actually need these elements to
have IDs it just needs us to put data
bindings on them now the very first
thing I'm going to do is remove the IDS
removing the ids is not necessary but
I'm taking them away just for clarity in
a real situation I might have a class on
each of these describing what they do
that way our CSS can hook on to it and
style it and make it look pretty so now
our h2 div and image all have data bind
attributes here first let's talk about
the h2 we want the h2 to be wired up
with the name of the cat in fact more
specifically we want the text of the h2
to be whatever the name of a cat is
knockouts binding for this is text name
whatever the name property is on the
view model over in our javascript file
that's what the text of this h2 gets set
to and in fact if we hop back over to
our app we can see there is the name
right there its initial value should be
tabby if I save my work and hop back
over here and refresh we should see the
name update with tabby let's hop back to
our HTML this div here is going to be
very similar the text inside of the div
is going to be the click account now the
image itself is going to be a little bit
different first of all we know that when
we click we want increment counter to
run we also want the source attribute of
this image to update as the source
changes in this simple example it won't
change but we still want to use
knockouts binding system to do this to
put multiple bindings inside of a data
bind just use a comma the way you bind
an attribute inside of a knockout is
with the binding attr colon and then an
object literal here with source to
whatever you want to bind it to in this
case in app DJ s
it's called image source if the image
source observable were ever to change
then the attribute source on this image
would change let's save this and go back
to our browser and see if it works sure
enough the image pops up and when you
click the number increments pretty cool
now once again these bindings are the
things that are connecting up the view
and the model and knockout is handling
all of the logic to make that
synchronization happen